now according to grabian Media CNN and
MSNBC have likened Trump to Hitler only
12 times so far today oddly they haven't
labeled the anti-semitic loons on
college campuses with that same
pejorative Jo me now tulsey galbert
former Democrat Hawaii congresswoman at
Fox News contributor um Tulsa there're
actually signs pramas signs anti-semitic
signage and
chance um at at these college campuses
and in cities and nothing oh yeah that's
fine but Trump he's he's Hitler now yeah
the hypocrisy is Rich L you said that
they only uh referred to him 12 times in
one day as Hitler why don't you go back
to to
2016 I'll tell you a brief personal
story two weeks after Trump was elected
in 2016 I was invited to go and speak to
him about foreign policy about how to
defeat radical Islam and terrorist
groups like Isis and Al-Qaeda and just
for meeting with Trump almost all
Democrats in Congress and those on TV
resoundingly criticized me for
humanizing Trump how dare you and they
were so angry about this because it
directly undermined what they were
trying to do in dehumanizing Trump and
everyone who voted for him the so-called
deplorables uh because they were try
they they couldn't defeat him on
substance and not only did they do that
back in 2016 they did it throughout his
administration but now we have
anti-sites all over the United States
boldly proclaiming frankly their
anti-Semitism calling it something else
yes and the Biden Administration seems
to be giving them Aid and comfort that's
what it's like you know I know they're
going to say anything about Trump that's
what they've always done but the turning
the Blind Eye to Hamas and what's been
done I mean to me that's wild but tsy
Trump's defense team in his New York
Civil Trial began uh presenting their
case today and Beyond the actual case
what stood out to me was look at Leticia
James and this smirk she had in her face
when Don Jr took the stand you know
first it was that judge with a goofy
smile that anger on and now um you see
these political prosecutions are are
what they are persecutions is another
example of their hypocrisy in one breath
they talk about defending democracy and
we heard Jen saki on MSNBC saying you
know if you elect Trump you're going to
undermine the rule of law and throw his
political opponents in jail look at what
they are doing right now and you see
that in the smirk on Leticia James face
they know exactly what they're doing
undermining the rule of law to try to
make it so that voters don't have the
opportunity to decide who they want to
vote for yeah well look they're enjoying
every every minute of this but I think
less and less people put stock in this
in this these types of prosecution and
the American people aren't stupid they
think that we are and that they can just
get away with this but I think the
American people are seeing exactly what
they're doing that the Democrat
establishment is going after Trump
because they're afraid of him and they
cannot challenge him on substance
whether it's the economy securing the
Border or foreign policy in the issues
of peace and War do you agree they're
freaking out I mean that political piece
today said he has no capacity to
campaign like a regular person and the
staff knows they're afraid of it afraid
of him going out there they are saying
what I think a lot of people have been
thinking for a long time I mean should
they not be asked about this at the
press conference absolutely they should
answer questions about it great to see
you as always in studio hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else